program features live coverage of an
African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to a spectacular start to
afternoon Safari with one of our lipids
we don't see all that often these days
but it is very nice to see in the form
of Herkimer you can see he's looking as
bulky in as big as ever and you've come
at just the right time because he's been
sleeping all afternoon and has just
decided to wake up in the last 20
seconds and is now off on a mission
which is not ideal because he's going to
cover grounds much quicker then we want
him to do these cool kind of conditions
means that he might start heading off
towards sort of triage downside and
might even cross out before I'll show
this evening but I'm hoping he's gonna
find a warthog or something in the
meantime
my name is crystal on camera I've got
sensor and it is a very very very warm
welcome to all of you you remember have
you are coming to you live from South
Africa and so if you have any questions
about for community then let us know on
hashtags for I live on Switzer Oh as if
see on the YouTube a chat stream and
remember to keep it relevant which I
would suggest would be all things
Leopard today because James is going
towards to be out he's gonna be heading
towards or Sean and Jamie's also outs
and she's gonna be scratching around for
Tandy or who was seen there late this
morning and then ting Hana was was her
around this morning so she's gonna also
have a little look around and so
hopefully we'll have a lipid trifecta be
seems like he spotted something not sure
what it is hopefully it's going to be
something like a warthog because we know
who Komori loves a warthog when it comes
to hunting I'm gonna try and see if I
can get around it gets a bit of view of
whatever's going on here
so just gonna try and hid in this
direction very exciting way to start
there isn't it the best thing about it
is that we have I have a very special
person on the back who has been dying to
see who can worry for a very long time
so Molly is on the back with me Hollie
do you want to say hello quickly
yes there we go there is Polly's saying
hello because he has been wanting to see
her Kumari for the longest time and so
he is super excited that he's managed to
come across his leopard that he wanted
to see so I'm super glad that we managed
to bring him with us for the afternoon
so he's going to enjoy some hookah
Murray time with me this afternoon now
what has he seen the way he's reacting
is he's running towards the nearest
termite mound they're just trying to get
across a little ditch quickly when you
have lots of you are very happy to see
Molly and to see that he's doing well he
is very well he's been studying hard for
his upcoming for Garcia exams and so I'm
hoping that he's going to be able to
pass very very well where is he gone not
right now we're gonna try catch up with
Luca Murray we're not very close to
where James is but James in the meantime
has got his own spotted cat down yeah
Gary damn good afternoon here we sit
with the little treif Ohana and he is at
his normal pantry of the damn pan now
you'll notice that we are very far away
from him today and I shall explain why
my name is James Henry
on camera today we have got Sebastian
Han Dini he used to be of course the
greatest French Gabonese air force pilot
in history until the demise of his
aircraft right what we are doing is
parking quite far away from the water
hole here we have watched him try and
hunt here before and Impala are really
very nervous of absolutely everything
and so what we've done is we've parked
far enough away from the water that we
think if some Empire come down they will
still drink despite our being here and
that means we won't be intruding at all
on asanas ability to hunt now he's been
pretty much in this position for the
whole day those have you been watching
the damn Campbell know this and we're
not going to move from here and that's
going to be a little bit irritating for
some of you I think if he decides to lie
down because he will then become
invisible but I'm going to resist the
temptation to move because as soon as we
disturb what's going on around here we
disturbed the kind of peace around this
waterhole the chances of him being able
to catch something that comes down to
drink or the chances of anything coming
down to drink will be reduced so if you
don't mind I'm going to ask that you
bear with me for the next two hours and
you know we couldn't talk about anything
else you likely can talk about him too
but this is the best picture we're going
to get it of him unless he decides to
get up and starts talking something so I
hope that you don't mind that that's
what we're going to do and that will be
our approach for the afternoon okay now
Jamie Patterson has also got a
magnificent creature to show you you
won't believe what it is
well I mean I have several magnificent
creatures James and Seb have a horse
owner Tristan and since I have hooker
Maria and David and I have some birds a
very good afternoon to you all my name
is Jaime and this afternoon
Davi is on camera with me and I'm
actually quite serious about how
exciting this is a submission of
starlings
and there's about 30 of them from the
greater blue eared Starling including
virtuals Starling as well there's lots
and lots of them they're just
unfortunately quite difficult now they
were all gathered together in the road
and then there's the horn ball with an
identity crisis who appears to think
that he is a starling but I really have
never seen this many hormones look at
him
there's many starlings or combines
together a proper murmuration of about
30 plus it is actually a feeding party
so it's not just the horn ball with the
identity crisis there are a number of
other birds that just saw a white
crowned Shrike somewhere I would tell
Dobby where it is but I don't know
anymore
there you go every single tree appears
to have at least one Starling in it
Dobby remember the Silas days where
after a long night out one would go to
attempt to sleep in the guide tents that
we were in and next to us at all times
they were starlings make an absolute
racket screeching constantly wasn't
really their fault I mean you know we
weren't meant to be asleep during the
day that's awesome it would be a lot
more effective on a nice sunny day but
the weather is truly unpleasant today
cosider says the hornball is cool look I
think the starlings are cool too they
would be cooler if you could see them
all in the sunlight
but perhaps the the horn ball is
actually too cool for the rest of the
horn balls and has decided to hang out
with the Troublesome pack of Starling
starlings and naughty Birds confident
noisy often regulars around campsites
and camps so perhaps the the horn Bell
has fallen into some bad company that's
why is working on his mohawk their black
mohawk down the middle of his head
puffed up you so cold I know guys it's a
miserably chilly day little bit of rain
little sprinkling of rain this morning I
also happen to see tungee just by the
way I tried to follow her I was going to
babysit her
he didn't go well I lost her moving on
someone who does have a leopard let's go
to Tristan who hasn't managed to lose
her Komori yet indeed we do have a lipid
and it's his trademark kind of position
that he's in he laid out in the dark
he's up and moving once more so as you
can see he's going to come past us
shortly
his wait for him to kind of move before
I shift around leaving very very nice to
the car which is awesome so nice to have
him but I don't know what he spots it is
what is something he's very very
intrigued by I apologize if he heard me
move my cap unfortunately it was twisted
on my mic pack so I just wanted to move
it quickly right
looks where you off to race is living
now is gonna be gone in the next half an
hour which is not ideal that's all let's
see how we go maybe you'll find
something and end up catching it said we
can gotta stay with him what are you
sniffing yes nothing very very very
heavily around on the ground there I
don't know if he spotted warthogs what
maybe he spotted something that he
thought would be a feasible hunting
option maybe saw another leopard but I
don't see any flippin promise but you
see the guy's noses to the ground look
you see house smelling he's trying to
work out what's going on it's not very
far from where we had the Lions
yesterday
but didn't really walk in this direction
we didn't have any tracks in this
direction when we were tracking them at
first but that's not to say over time
they didn't get you with trishula Conte
remember waitress Charlotte she followed
the Lions yesterday and it was in this
direction maybe that's what he's picking
up with he sniffing he's sending
something often if it's an animal that
lies down a lot they also smell like
that so something like a darker or a
steelbook those things also catch their
attention - but what was interesting is
he was fast fast fast asleep he was kind
of sitting flat on his side and all of a
sudden the wind came up and he was up
like a shot and then running and you
could see there's some sort of an
intrigue that he's got and something
that he's watching he's gonna sit down
all right so since it's really salsa
[ __ ] still can't shake the silly cold
that I've got so do apologize if you
hear me sniffing now a lot of you are
wondering where singhania's welting
Ghana was lift this morning he was left
in puffles hook so pretty much straight
north from where we are at the moment
but insides
purfles hook in an area near Chicana now
Turkana is quite far to the north so I
don't think he's here waiting on ER
which would be back this far just yet
but you never know sorry I was just
trying to tell the guys cuz they were
into park ahead of us in case he moved I
was trying to tell them that they he's
gone down and he's just sitting at the
moment I don't think he's gonna be down
for long but whatever it was that he
possibly saw maybe he picked up the
cyntia realized it's not something that
he actually wants to deal with and it's
just lay down again oh he's just sitting
and waiting to smell or listen pick up
any other sign again before he decides
to move on but he's very alert you see
he's picking and looking around the
direction we just came from so I don't
know what it is that he's smelling but
I'll sit with him for a while I'm gonna
see what happens in the meantime they
they send you back across to husana he's
in a similar spot
we are still here as I said I must tell
you also that sandy the female leopard
sister to horse Anna gramby sister to
horse honor was found yes I'm speaking
quietly how's the audio Sebastian I'm
sorry yes goat goat okay right Sundy was
very close to camp in fact during the
course of the morning and Jamie spent an
extended period with her waiting to see
what she would do and then she got up
and disappeared by walking into the camp
pretty much between stop village in the
camp and she might pop out here at some
stage impossible to get a vehicle into
where she was going and in fact she was
so displeased with Jamie that Jamie
thought she wouldn't even try and follow
her in for the vehicle so she's around
here somewhere maybe we'll get to see
her a little bit later or Sanne hasn't
moved at all he's eyeing up the Impala
that you were looking at and then
there's in parlor of course are just
sort of shopping I suppose on the little
green shoots that have come out as a
result of the small rains we had today
and the heavy mr. Sebastian pointed out
to me that we had over the last few
morning's say that's what's going on
there there there are
that's not grass that's little the water
weeds that tend to pop up after water or
sauna is watching them but of course he
will not do very well to expose himself
at this stage and for those of you who
perhaps haven't been watching for a
while or maybe you're a new viewer or
sila the three-year-old male leopard 8
and Impala almost in its word let's say
he had 2/3 of it about winters that was
on probably Thursday Wednesday or
Thursday and so I don't think he's very
hungry but he could certainly eat again
today and there are some Impala that are
showing some intent to come back down
here and have a drink
but you see because it's not a
particularly cold day I'm not sure that
they're going to rush down to have a
drink
JB yes there is a possibility that the
Pumped water at this pan may run out it
comes from the same borehole or aquifer
that sorry I paused cuz I thought I
heard a monkey alarming but I didn't it
comes from the same aquifer that feeds
our camp and so if it runs out yes
indeed as we too will go the way of all
flesh that can't get water so this pan
will do the same unfortunately so we do
have to watch out we have to conserve
water we are unlikely to get a proper
deluge before the end of the year and so
it is possible that our aquifer could
run dry and that means that this pan
will run dry at the same time and then
horse owners pantry will have to be
sought elsewhere now also know of course
can afford to just lie here by the pan
because he's not territorial he has no
inclination to mark himself a territory
and so unlike his father who was
wandering around or peeing on bushes and
shouting his head off in order
to maintain his territory and keep
intruders from taking it from him or
sarna can just sit here just vegetate
next to the water and wait for something
to come and then he will try and catch
it and as the driest season take Holt
takes hold I'm hoping that he finds this
place as productive as he always has
he's in a very good spot if anything
comes down to drink I think you'll have
a good chance of having a go at the
moment the only thing that's had a drink
down here is a laughing dove as always
peaceful and quiet on Sunday afternoon
here at Juba private game reserve lowest
infringers of the Grand Poobah National
Park
you can hear not a great deal of
birdsong a couple of virtuals starlings
gang squawking squawking behind us
Firefly yes and no I suppose that
concentration of lions certainly effects
the density of other predators they
certainly would move away if for example
there was a land in on the reserve you'd
find that that den would be given a wide
berth but I don't think that it would
change the territories of the resident
male and female leopards and so although
it may well be a situation where
leopards might avoid a certain area they
wouldn't reduce or contract their
territories that said you know 10 Ghana
was on a territorial patrol that he
smoked lion he would not be so terrified
that he wouldn't try and investigate
what he was smelling and if he then came
across a den of course he'd kill those
Cubs he wouldn't think twice about it I
don't think there's a den on Juma though
I know that there is a den but I just
really feel like the amount of time we
spend driving around this reserve and
walking it flat I really feel like we
would have seen it or certainly seen
evidence of lionesses going in and out
of an area and so I'm gonna say I don't
think that there were any youngsters
here I think they might don't be fools
hook to the north of us that would make
the most sense this that that's the
least activity
nor the place with the least activity
and therefore I think that's most likely
taught or sauna can see down into the
dam seems to be looking quite intently
across the way there is it another
little hoid of impalas coming this way
perhaps and ah what a tiger
apparently pajamas Patterson is taking
what's known as a humble dumble
I'm taking a humble bumble what a
brilliant way of phrasing that that is
now how I shall refer to bumbles forever
afterwards where are you off to I'm on a
humble bumble that's great my humble
bumble has not produced any kind of
sighting as yet and it doesn't mean I've
given up hope though he's going to tell
you my tündi story so this morning she
was called in just after drive right
outside our camp and she was lying down
in a drainage line and I went in there
just to babysit her for the rest of the
day I'm gonna switch around so that we
could keep an eye on her and June came
in for those of you don't know Jude is a
hyena and she just harassed and harassed
and harassed tündi or she actually
didn't harass her she just walked all
the way around checking to see if there
was a kill around tündi didn't find
anything then tündi walked through the
drainage line and then I was parked on
opposite side for some reason decided
she really would didn't like me this
morning came bouncing up and stopped
just so I could see her eyes and her
ears and she just hissed at me
it's a tündi smile for what felt like
quite a long period of time because I'm
quite short in the Mahindra's I couldn't
really see anything except her eyes and
I certainly wasn't gonna sit up on the
door though he held eye contact for a
very long time and then she went and lay
down next to me
we heard cat and then June came in and
Tandy just lost it she got so angry that
she chased jounin I mean Tony's about
half the weight of June she just chased
her all the way through the camp and
gone I couldn't keep up with her well
it's not that I could actually couldn't
keep up with her like there was no way I
could have driven through the staff
quarters to get around shouldn't go into
the camp but she moved through
underneath the elephant wire that was my
morning with Tandy which I feel like
would make a very good title for a book
honey and other stories and my plan from
now is to try and see if I can find her
again
don't know where to start though cuz
it's tiny
no way to start though cuz sunny it
could be also chickens little eyes back
in from torch he maybe bottles of damn
there's not that many places for them to
drink feeling that some elephants we
will go to the Enid in a bit later to
see if they're there all sorts of
proverbial sleeves
like area
okay apparently my signals a little bit
low in this area that tündi likes no
surprise there
I send you a cross to Tristan who's
doing his best to keep up with her
Komori well hopefully Jamie will find
where the signal is and she'll be okay
as you can see Herkimer he is busy since
marking he's also got the sneezes he
seems to have got some grass or dust up
his nose because he's seen it a few
times and kind of has rubbed his face a
little bit as well so wonder if it's not
something that's just irritating his
nose a little bit at the moment but
anyway he's on a serious mission he's
turned heavily to the east now so he was
hidden stably going south he's now
hitting deep into Juma
I mean we're hitting at this rate if he
just stays on the course that he's on
now we'll hit at P at Philemon stop
fairly shortly so he's moving quite
quickly and like I say straight east at
the moment which in some respects is
good other respects not so good given
that's obviously husana has been hanging
around central Jima trade he went to a
Camry to pick up his scent and try and
follow him what interests me though is
that this morning there's two things
that are very interesting first thing
I'll get into which is not related to
this at all and the second thing is
related the first thing is that kochava
was seen today steve was looking for
some animals for tonight's show and he
managed to bump into kochava
yeah in the day and she's hula by the
looks of things and from the guides that
were able to follow her inside tortured
she apparent he looks like she's got
some Cubs at the moment which is quite
interesting so for those of you that
were wondering about each other since
the last time she was seen is it does
look like she has Cubs so hopefully
there'll be some news on those fairly
soon and then the other sort of related
topic is that ting gana today was seen
in an area where we have not seen him
for many many many many months
sandy Patchi area will tell axis and I
haven't seen taganas a since he was been
sick it's not to say he hasn't caught me
but that's just where I haven't seen him
and so what's interesting is that
coincides with her camera being back on
the property that he's pushed that far
waste I wonder if he didn't hear her
come hurry come this side and
maybe just maybe came to investigate
what was going on and they might have
even been a little bit of kind of you
know shouting at one another sometimes
male lipids that's how they settle their
disputes as they shot at each other and
and that's how things get sorted sorry
since we're gonna have to try and figure
out another way through here which is
not going to be all that's easy let's
try from here all right I'm gonna try
and get through here this might be a bit
interesting and a bit tricky and so
while I do that let's send you back
across to James with hasana who's being
far kinder to James and is just sitting
pretty lucky interest and has got Paulie
to lift him out of trouble
powerful young man particularly keen on
running I must tell you but he is a
strong young fellow we have not moved as
I promised we would not Sanne
I think getting bored actually in Satya
the whole day a nice trying to find out
why it is that his patience isn't paying
off I also think that his attention has
been alerted by some alarm calling birds
and I think that Andy is not far from
here cat yes I think that all sonic is
lazy er today because of the weather
I don't we often say well it's a cool
day the Predators might walk today might
move around during the middle of the day
in my experience that isn't actually the
case if it's cold and miserable I sleep
when it's cold and miserable but if it's
I mean and we've often seen predators
especially livers moving around in the
most blinding of summer heat so yeah I
think that they are a little bit like us
I don't see why there wouldn't be this
weather makes us feel sort of down
and lethargic and I think that's got to
do with sunlight and its effect on
vitamin D and melatonin and other
hormones that perhaps would give us a
bit more energy and inspire us to
greater things when it's sunny which
really makes you wonder how on earth
Britain never managed to create an
empire because if I lived in Britain I
would be lethargic 24 hours a day
maybe that John was probably how they
did it
I just left in droves I'm scanning the
area for his sister but with my
binoculars I have yet to see any sign
you know we'll continue our stakeout
with husana I'm a I know this will
probably irritate it Sebastian as much
as it'll irritate you I may move even
for slightly further back in same angle
just a little bit further away but we'll
see
and the game drive radio has now become
deeply excited by the presence of lipids
oh here we go
hello magic dragon was odd I don't know
if for Sylar we'll stay here I'm really
if I was to guess one way or t'other and
that guests were to prove correct it
would have been nothing but blind luck
so I don't know I don't know what he's
gonna do I don't know what his plan is
what his desires are I don't really see
why he should leave at the moment Oh
Marie seems to found himself a snack
I'm gonna wait here that's alright hey
don't sponsor me I can't see what it is
I think it's potentially some sort of
poo Betty's busy easy I know it doesn't
sound very good but he looks like he's
got two dirty nose doesn't he and so it
brings new meaning to the word
brown-noser but he's probably shoving
his nose into some sort of dung they
often do do this and they roll around
and it's and it's it's something that
male lipids do particular with Buffalo
dung but it's I can't see anything there
and we don't have any Buffalo around
really so my guess is that it's maybe
wildebeest or something that he's busy
sorting out or there is the scent of
something he's very interested in but I
suspect it's more done I don't see any
carcass or anything like that but it's
he was walking steadily and he just
stopped right here and started rolling
and is now biting and sniffing about and
so it's a bit tricky to figure out
exactly what he's got there what it is I
like I said I suggest dung is probably
the best sort of guess that I have and
like I said I'd imagine it's probably
wildebeest they at the moment are
leaving quite a lot of dung in this area
and they spend a lot of time down the
side aisle to be heard from quarantine
so what do you think sends I think
that's what we've got maybe it's been a
lone Buffalo moving around we know there
has been a buff around but I don't think
we've seen any tracks for him out this
side now I believe a lot of you again
ooh well it's just really grass that is
passed through a digestive system
essentially there's really not much to
antelope done and so it's not that bad
to be honest I mean and in South Africa
there's even that game where you put
food in your mouth and you try and spit
it as far as you can antelope whoo that
is an Impala is normally the one that
people use although sometimes people
upgrade to a bigger caliber like giraffe
or kudu but the bigger calibers are not
really that's easy in comparison to
Impala Pooh same part of you is normally
the one that's kind of mostly used and
to see how far you can split it so it
really is just processed grass more than
anything else but Komori seems to love
it he for some reason has got his face
buried
in what it is sometimes you'll find
these male lipids that their whole face
looks black from doing this I mean we've
seen a sauna sometimes with his head
like that's a Kumari where are you going
where you've just come from there and
he's gonna st. mark I wonder if there's
not a scent of another liquid here that
he is picking up maybe ting gana walked
her maybe husana maybe there's been a
female but she can seize definitely
smelling but his dirty nose hello boy if
you watch your nose on the ground makes
me wonder if maybe he's picked up the
scent of ting gana
you see looks in marking as well typical
winner leopard smells another one the
only thing that says suggest that he
potentially hasn't smelled too mailed it
but is that he's not salivating normally
when a male lipid smells another male
his salivation starts to happen and
that's because they start getting the
testosterone flooding and I start
getting amped up in order to try and
defend the eteri are you going to lie
there he's lying in a very horrid place
I also need to turn to face you guys the
right away before Kirsty shots at me
guys in next week's review I'll be
shouted at for not facing the right way
so there we go but he's looking really
good isn't he I mean he's at the moment
he's come off for a kill he was on a
kill I was so close to getting shot at
did you see Christy tell him in my ear
thanks Christy yeah you see I was quick
there to realize that I was in trouble I
was in the danger zone but he looks good
he's just come off a kill like I say or
fareth you say I think he had a warthog
there for a few days he's looking very
very well at the moment his overall body
condition is looking good
he seems to always look more and more
impressive as the days go on you know
when you first arrived here is it's kind
of scraggly and didn't really look that
bulky but he's bulked up quite nicely
and he's looks like a serious fella
these days I quite like him I know a lot
of people don't you might soar listen
listen listen he's growling a little bit
if he drops his head again I'm gonna
keep quiet because that's often when
they saw
leaving almost on my father saw that he
made this little low grumble and they
dropped their head and that's often when
they saw they saw into the ground like
that so I wouldn't be surprised if you
do hear a saw at some point soon
mr. he's got his nose down on the ground
I would imagine he's smelling another
cats over which cat that could be I
don't um there's definitely another cat
that's been around here that's
intriguing her Maria at this stage and
like I said could be tiny could be
Columbo it could be should tell you it
could be really anyone or they should
duel you I don't think so because she
essentially has been seen almost every
day on Arethusa over the course of the
last few weeks but we did have a track
that came from this area about two days
ago and I wasn't sure who it was it
eventually crossed into Atari and so
maybe just maybe there's a female that
but that walk three it could be a ton D
or something like that that has been
here and especially of Tani's but had
Cubs and starts coming into any stris
that will be of severe interest to a
lipid like don't worry
he obviously wants to try and reproduce
as much as possible so I'm intrigued to
see away this takes him and if he
follows a scent because that'll give us
an indication of who it is if he phone
has a sink north east towards the dam
then we know he's following potentially
tandy right now her camera is getting
comfortable and there's a gal about to
roll on his back like a little kitten
but in the meantime there's before more
serious business going on at Gary dam as
her sauna begins to hunt we have gotten
a little hunt going on here
now what he's doing is he's gonna try
and sneak between here and some bushes
behind which those Impala have now moved
now we've been very very nice to him by
staying away you won't believe it but
another vehicles sort of pulled up and
they've too been very sensitive about
the situation but they're actually in
the perfect position now can you see
with the Impala is this if it's red in
front of us and there's a vehicle behind
it so what he's trying to do everybody
you see that greenery there
he's now I think going to try and get
into that greenery so that he can get at
the heard of him parlor that that one
belongs to that one belongs to a herd of
about ten or so that was eating down in
the dam I don't know where the rest of
them are there must be just behind that
one so if the dam cam can see them and
what's interesting is that I don't think
any of those in part of drank from the
scummy water down in the dam and I
wonder if they're not gonna think about
coming here I can now see two Impala
there so they're gonna make their way up
into the clearings I don't think they're
going to come down here to drink three
and that's why he was interested you see
a parent a number of you asking if the
lapwings going to dive-bomb the small
chief I don't think they are going to
dive on the small chief because I don't
think that the lapwings have got
youngsters at the moment you can see
them they're moving away from the
waterhole now as he watches no dart
feeling a sense of [ __ ] irritation
something profoundly amusing about a
leopard when he flattens his ears like
that he's in such a great position if
anything came down to drink her well
except you'd have to burst other they
probably trip and fall into the water
before we got close to anything see what
he does here they've all got their backs
turned to him I'm not gonna move
we're gonna keep as quiet as possible so
I'm not to drop anything in the car said
they'd look this way
if they start grazing here you might try
and stalk up to them but I think not I
think they're going up towards
quarantine clearings were probably
settle for the evening who apparently
the lapwings do have eggy's at the
moment
well yes then they could easily dive
bomb or sauna if he's anywhere near
their eggy's I don't know where their
AG's are and I take my hat off to the
dedicated and brilliant zoomy who
managed to find the eggy's using the
damn camp there is your pity Schiff you
like that Sebastian
five another ring terrain liberty ship
is just thinking about the remaining
Impala in the bushes there watching that
impalas friends thinking to himself
should i shouldn't i knowing he
shouldn't but perhaps being unable to
overcome his sense of impatience
cap the reason he's hanging around this
location is that it's the only water in
the area or some of the only water in
the area and many predators choose this
as a strategy to try and kill they'll
hang around water holes and as it gets
drier and drier so also will they have
more and more success he also of course
has learned that this is a good place to
be from his years as a young non
territorial male leopard
he's probably spent about I'm gonna say
as much as 20% maybe 15 or 20 percent of
his time here and it's proved very
fruitful for him he has killed much that
has come down to have a drink sometimes
in broad daylight sometimes in the
evening and an Impala seems to have a
profoundly short memory which is much to
his advantage although they are normally
nervous when they come down to drink
because they do suspect that there is
something trying to eat them all the
time because there is normally something
trying to eat them all the time they
seem to become no more fearful than they
would be otherwise at this waterhole all
he has to do is hide for a couple of
hours and they'll come wandering down
again yeah that unfortunately is going
to be that for horse owners little hunt
still was quite funded
well done Hosanna whoo now the lung Keys
have either spotted him Effendi they're
starting to cool and that's why he's put
his head down but just be able to hear
the monkey starting to alarm
Tandi is around here somewhere
and whether that monkey has seen him or
sauna I couldn't say they have very good
eyes of course
some monkey again in French Miss song no
I find that words a deeply amusing all
right apparently the humble bumbler is
still looking for Tandy four three two
one the humble bumble I'm very far away
from where those monkeys are alarm
calling but I do feel as though the
humble bumble is a sort of one step on
the path to enrichment it sounds like
one of those spiritual journeys one
might take I'm really enjoying my humble
bumble I'm buoyed by the the joy of
imagining Polly's face when he saw Marie
that's what's been it's it's completely
lifted my spirits on this gloomy
afternoon I'm so so happy for him our
beloved Polly got hehe oh man it's just
so cool I'm so happy for him he's been
dying to see who could worry and so so
thrilled then we got to make it also
goes Shar long it's been since we've
seen hooker Morrie properly but anyway
hmm okay we have arrived at Buffalo down
I sort of thought Tanya might have moved
this way if she wasn't around the lodge
but I think she might be what do we have
we do not have scuba we do not have Sara
we no longer have a heron Hey well done
Davi
I can hear frantic squeaking from the
Dorf Mongoose but I can't see them well
done dog awesome hmm a plus camerawork
says Kirstie I know absolutely now where
these dwarf Mongoose cuz I can hear them
but I cannot see them hoping there might
be a leopard here or some lions I was
actually really hoping for some lions
one of the only places they can come and
drink in this corner but nay it is not
to be the humble bumble is not for the
faint of heart
but we will have to continue on with it
until we reach our journey's completion
whatever that may be what to do do I go
check the boundary for the lines and
kochava do i race back and place my bets
on tündi in the dark try and stay with
her in the dark or round Galago hmm
we've got we've got two leopards already
I'm inclined to say we'll stick with our
current our current process and hope
that she makes her way out onto a road
and maybe one of the other vehicles
there's a lot of vehicles working around
that area maybe one of them will see it
just doesn't make logical sense to me to
go racing off there when there's so many
other people looking out for leopards
that side as well alright we're going to
humbly bumbly off towards the eastern
boundary now I think that's my idea
Arpi welcome to our live safari our
pieces I want to see a lion me too
RP I will make it my mission in life to
try and show you a lion provided there
are Lions on Juma or indeed even if
there are Lions not on Juma but
somewhere within the range of our camera
I would really like to see a lion - I
would like to see a lioness I failed
dismally yesterday at finding them here
I have to tell you about my life
yesterday you know you have a rehearsal
for our TV show on a Saturday night and
a Friday night but last night was
Saturday and we we did an ad break I
mean we do account we do practice ad
breaks where we go countdown into where
the TV ads come in and my idea in theory
it was a good idea was that he was going
to roar going into the ad break what he
did was at 10 seconds started going hmm
and then as Kirstie says okay hold off
speaking as we went into the ad break he
started roaring it was great I was so
proud of him what a Jim
the line of speaking
yeah we should be fine
it's just the truth I I have this dream
should have been all right here but
unfortunately we're not now we're going
to send you back across to James and
husana apparently my timing with the
signal dips is shocking this afternoon
for what her dream has to do the signal
but that's fair enough
here is husana he is now moved and come
the other side of the damn wall
now he walks towards us he's looking at
where ting gana was yesterday and I was
confess the petty chef is not looking
particularly fat after his meal so I
feel like he could probably meet again
coming down to where his meal was hello
everyone I'm just trying to stay out of
your way
if he certainly does not look like a
lipid he's just had a meal I must say he
looks fairly hombre
he's going to have a dump it's nice to
see
well done Hosanna then Thank You
Sebastian for the modesty with which you
were shooting this particular scene
marry as far as I'm aware things like
burying the poopoo are instinctual
behaviors in other words I don't think
he learns to do them it's possible that
he watched his mother dirt and that's
why he does it
I'm not convinced that's the case
because you know he'd have left his
mother by the time he started bearing
his done I suspect not
I don't know we're going to try and
avoid driving over that particular but
have done and he hasn't buried that and
the reason he hasn't made it and it does
smell something evil is because he
doesn't have a kill here and so he's not
really trying to avoid being seen or
smelt in this case now this could get
quite nasty from a following point of
view sure try and keep up with this cat
through here will not be a task for the
faint-hearted but we are going to try
they are going to be full of courage
aren't we sir Destin mm-hmm
here we go
how many of you're saying I need just to
collect the scat that's very true I
don't actually have a vial with me which
is not very good but at the same time we
do have much of his sket and so then
really neatest that would have been a
good one
a very good one he's having a little
trot now
oh he's so perfectly camu camu fledged
for this area turnoff he's just over
there sip he looked like he'd seen
something
I of course not the only one trying to
keep up with a leopard
Tristan Dix is also to one
indeed James we also trying our level
best since I'm just gonna go back in
little bits just so we can get out of
his path
that's we're trying to keep up with her
Kumari as well which is obviously easier
said than done because he's on a serious
serious mission at the moment and he's
heading straight north now is changed
direction completely and so we're up
towards quarantine ow and if he didn't
hear the very monkeys alarm calling and
that's why his direction has changed
obviously so he's a concern when he
changes direction like this because we
know Hassan is in that direction and
prasanna unfortunately is getting to the
point now with all the disturbances that
he's had in the form of lions and
tenganan the risk he's gonna have to
start standing up for himself if he is
to stay here and he's gonna have to
start standing up to leopards like this
and try and make himself kind of seem a
lot bigger so we gonna have to try and
see what happens maybe he's gonna start
moving in komori whines getting to kind
of go and come into play but let's see
how we go
right
so kale how long until I think what you
say this how long until Hosanna could
challenge hooker Murray sorry there's
lots of people talking on the radio as
Casey was feeding it through um well the
day is coming where he's gonna have to
if he wants to be a territorial male
he's gonna have to start challenging and
whether that means challenging lakhs of
hooker Murray skittish male his dad's in
Ghana at some point he needs to stand up
for himself and say well I want to be
here and I'm going to do everything I
can to be here so that means trying to
be as territorially dominance as any
other lipid where he's gonna have to saw
he's gonna to st. mark he's gonna have
to show himself as a big male and not
back down which can be dangerous at
times but unfortunately that's the life
of a male lipid you at some point in
your life when you are young you have to
start standing up now if you think of
somebody like or some cat like who
calorie the amount of effort he's had to
go through in his life to become a
dominant male gives you an idea of how
hard it can be I think let's just stay
here since and it's not an easy job
being a dominant male leopard and it
certainly requires a lot of risks in
terms of taking on the leopards I don't
think Hassan is quite as big as her
Komori just yet certainly not as street
smarts no as bulky has a long way to go
I think until he can really stand up
physically as well as like I say
technically towards Murray it's not to
say that he can't put on a brave show
sometimes smaller lipids can chase off
larger if it's and Haku Marian Anderson
is a bit of an example by just being
brave and and far more aggressive it
does happen from time to time we lipids
you know put on this serious kind of
show to make sure that everybody
understands that they're the dominant
male but to give you an idea of where we
are cuz it's quite interesting from here
we're quite high so you can see if you
zoom arts from way hooker Murray is
walking that in the background his
quarantine on top there so just the
direction yet to walk straight now he's
going to be on the southern side of
quarantine that open clearing on the top
of the ridge there that's where
quarantine is and husana is on the other
side of that Ridge at the dam so it
gives you an idea of kind of where we
are but I have a
a key suspicion that it's not husana
that he's tracking Hank he's tracking
ting Ghana's st. that's what my sneaky
suspicion is because he's not hitting
more than a Northwest and we note in
Ghana has been around these areas and so
maybe that's where he's tracking or he's
tracking Tandy who was came out of the
strange this morning that he's heading
into and maybe she's coming into an East
Resaca saying that's why he's kind of
following in behind her but where he's
going
is the hooker moaning kind of special it
is the most nasty horrible block in the
world and so we're going to try and
follow him through it and see if we can
manage in the meantime therapy I believe
Jaime Patterson had a dream and she
would like to tell us all about it I
have a dream you know what it's I feel
this has been works I'd be up out of
proportion here I fell I will tell you
what my I didn't actually have a dream I
have a goal that I would like to work
towards in that sense and by the way I
think if anyone can follow hook amore
Tristan can my dream is to start because
you know how we have the Versa Safari
live openings for the for these safaris
my ideal is to have the perfect timing
coincide as a lion roars and starts
roaring as the disclaimer starts playing
we have the disclaimer in the beginning
you know this program features animal
kills and carcasses whatever it may be
features a live African safari animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised that I start strong then and you
don't say anything you just hit the line
raw and raw and raw and play it all out
right next to you and then you just turn
it on and say this is fiery life that is
my dream I toyed with the best approach
to that you know should I do this is a
lion and this is Safari live or but I
feel like it would have the most impact
with just this this Safari live so
that's my dream or an ape it's all and
not once have I
he not once have I managed to get the
timing spot on with my openings we are
because he made me giggle there for a
second she reminded me of Steph's
amazing moment many years ago during a
rehearsal Steph had never done of us a
safari life opening but he was on walk
and none of us had animals so as they
were about to go live with him they
realized he'd never done one so they
said to him you have to say this is far
alive but you know obviously we do a
little 20-second spiel of this is so
exciting whatever this is very life and
Steph had no idea what was going on so
they said live live and stiff goes this
is Safari live I mean it was just this
awkward moment he looked at then Yali
was the king of it this is Anna Nala and
this is Safari life awkward his he Steve
can pull off oh man it was funny last if
we missed those moments we was trying to
figure out his thinking face I wish we
had that when you can see steps thinking
face when he gets a question through and
he hasn't quite heard the name and you
know he's gonna get the name wrong we
all do it my favorite trick is to go
would like to know you just make a sound
approximate to what I think I've heard
courtesy of the director I don't know
anything show you obviously that's why
I'm rambling about this down the eastern
boundary
he's a lot that goes on in terms of our
preparation for TV shows and the funny
moments that we have every now and again
I once did an opening with Ferg
who forgot about that this is Safari
live opening and he just stayed on the
zebra but by now I have my whole speech
planned out for the Lissa's file I've
opening and he did the slowest zoom art
ever and took forever so by the time I
managed to get this a safari live in I
was completely out of words desperate
and all that was visible was the corner
of my eye
this is safari knife anyway that was my
dream I'm sure that James has far more
complex and interesting dreams probably
starting this evening with husana
catching a meal
the little chief seems to be allowed to
pass on something but no idea what it is
Oh
look I suspect a scrub here
I think he's
I think I've just chewed a piece of
tambuti leaf everyone if I die you'll
know why
excuse me look okay
it was a bird you think so no it's kind
of a look
oh it was a bunny does he got it no no
he doesn't have there's a bunny here
there is the bunny
or the leopard has disappeared that
could be the end of that there is I
think the bird gave him away asana
looked your left is just on your left I
can see him
the money is literally 20 meters to his
left but he don't know he don't know
nothing about that
alrighty I'll just give him a little bit
of space
of course the darker it gets the less
space we can give him and still stay
with him
sorry I'll see I'm afraid I'll miss that
let's have it again the other radio was
going wonderful to have you with us as a
new viewer thank you for joining us what
was this about Africa oh you had no idea
that Bunny's in Africa well there are
scrub hairs and so yes there are some
kinds of bunnies in Africa much bunny
here in Africa Africa of course very
vast place about three times the size of
the continental United States
there he goes down through there and up
the other side held on tight everybody
lift your drinks up and be careful not
to knock your teeth out on your glasses
oh you should be able to get up here
you will probably turn and come straight
back down again and pull another bunny
is just squandered the other way to the
left I'm gonna go through here sit
I promise you that body Bush will get up
to Walter we've driven past it yes it's
just hit me in the elbow
shame I think he would have had that
bunny if there hadn't been a bird
between him and the bunny here now
apparently going to go to Jamie who is
doing something called driving on an ice
road alright
humble bumble continues I'm afraid I
have no news I'm now moving back into
the center of Jummah Rex and has found
the lines so we know at least we're
there I'm not going to waste any more
time checking the eastern boundary
anymore because they're on Torchwood
with the kudu not with a live could do
with the dead could do that they eating
which is great I'm glad they managed to
get themselves as a meal so that's where
they are at the moment sorry I can't
remember who it was it was a random
combination of letters RP wanted to see
a line I'm afraid at least the Lions I
was looking for or not they're on
Torchwood which is the property just to
the east of us doesn't mean we won't see
lions though just although know where
the males are they could pop in at any
moment
David thought he saw something on this
road we've both concluded it was his
imagination but we're driving down it
anyway just in case
hehehe calyx would like to know while I
search for things how the puppies doing
my puppy well you know I want Brent when
he named her my Salwa that people would
not be able to say Matt flora brent
cannot even say my flora he keeps
missing out the second owl anyway
naturally it has become shortened and
becomes flowy which because a lot of
people can't say that either 'he's
almost always Chloe so the dog is doing
very well she's very happy
Brent's doing a really really lovely job
with her she's house trained mostly she
says little accidents every now and
again she she's a very she's a Jack
Russell she is a force little force of
nature she no longer has to growl at the
stairs because she can't go up them she
can now jump up them and she no longer
growls to get down either she she used
to when she was a little bit younger
growl at the stairs and then full down
them that was her way of getting down
but she's just sort of priam to be
growled at the stairs in preparation she
doesn't have to do that anymore she's
very cute from the videos I've seen she
sounds really sad because is hmm she's
very sweet she has a favorite toy
it's a cow in case you were wondering
she's a little favorite and then brains
attached a bungee cord to the tree which
she loves she absolutely loves it's got
a little rope on the ends that she can
pull and she goes round and round and
round around pulling on the bungee cord
it's her best thing ever
brent is paranoid to the point of
hysteria at times trying to keep her
safe away from owls and leopards and all
sorts of other things
speaking of leopards I'm sure that her
Komori would consider Chloe a snack
fortunately she's quite far away from
him well I can attest to the fact that
brent is a complete little marshmallow
when it comes to that puppy and it runs
around trying to protect it as it goes
I wonder if Jamie's going to tell the
story of her little incident with the
puppy of late coming did you have to
walk right past us boy hmm
you're a pretty cat and she doing inside
yeah it's a beautiful animal
that's for sure sometimes you've just
got to stop and admire what a lipid
looks like because there's just
something about them that is spectacular
nah he's just behind the tree scent
marking swinging away for him to kind of
move pause Gaby yes ghost I got that
thank you very much and hook him where
his head is well yes it is bulky but
it's not massive it's just that his body
is slightly smaller than that of ting
ganas and so he's a head appears that
much larger but actually his head is
pretty actually smaller than what ting
ganas is ting honest just got such a big
body and jewel app that his head appears
a lot more in proportion than what you
would see with hooker Murray right I'm
gonna go back because otherwise we're
gonna lose him and it's quite tricky to
get in and out of this area so careful
there sins
alright I'm gonna try and get back
without seating a false Marino that's
next to me here decapitating sins our
parlors alarm calling so hooks did you
get spotted mob way it's amazing how
quickly this cat can move he covers
distance
it's like tündi in that regard moves
much faster than what you would expect
there is that please Roger good so now
were you going to try and catch up where
there is you busy sniffing a bush so
while we have a lawsuit look at Coco
Marie it sends you back across to James
who's trying to keep up with husana but
we are now driving through the thick
bush after Hosanna
he has gone north into I supposedly what
is essentially the mala mati
oops-a-daisy this is the Lord's stump in
the way right hold on tight everybody
going to be a little bit tough
we go over we are he's just over here
sniffing hunting looking very skinny I
must say there he goes I'll just get my
fat head out of the way and you can have
a look at him in I don't know what the
resting heart rate of a leopard is right
now is heart rate is I suspect probably
around about 120 beats per minute I
think is probably slightly faster than
the human beings
apparently all mammals and a
cardiologist told me once this once have
a sort of suit within certain boundaries
have the same number of heartbeats per
life and so something that is very
short-lived has a higher heart rate I
don't know what his heart rate is there
I'm guessing around about a hundred and
twenty now I'm not sure
he certainly doesn't do a great deal of
fitness exercises sir I suppose it's
probably quite quite high that said he
doesn't eat sugar or other things that
might push his heart rate up and his
blood pressure up all right here and now
he's going for some more thick bush okay
yeah I'm just gonna wait am i no I'm
gonna go up he goes back into the
drainage from here it's going to be
difficult to catch up with him
all right let's go back to Jamie while
we try and get through this rather
highness
piece of Boosh
good luck through the heinous bush
we had some elephants but they barreled
off to the south so I'm trying to go
round some on Ed Wood Road I assume
they're going to chew to a dam for a
drink for perhaps I might follow them
there but I just have to get through the
more party here to do sir my humble
bumble produced an animal but then it
ran away actually stable animals they
were large animals but they've
disappeared see if we can catch them I
think a bit of Ferrari Safari
but you never know we might find a
leopard on a ton dams - I haven't seen
elephants since for so long they might
go into twin dams come to think of it
there's not much water though it's not
very nice water
an elephant's a notorious fussy when it
comes to their state of their drinking
water if they can drink clean-ish with a
wolf they much prefer it and twin dams
is basically mud at the stage one jolly
good wallow from a herd of elephants and
it'll be gone but let's see they're mine
you can be either got a twin or two
Chitra
I assume they haven't been seen on a
damn camera alright I'm gonna go through
a couple of signal dips on my way to the
elephants while I do let's head across
there to hooker Maureen who's made it
out of the thickets and into the open
I still following oh c'mon use now
popped out onto quarantine and is
definitely on the trail of a leopard
which leopard it is I don't know but
there's been lots of Flemming grimacing
lots of smelling and looking
he's been shouted at by about forty
million other antelope as well and he is
on a bit of a mission at this stage
they're hitting sort of straight
northwards I'm gonna try and just repeat
turn you should hear a kudu bark shortly
which I'll try to norv for
James with the age difference between
hooker Marie and husana difficult to say
because we don't have any accurate age
for her Kumari but we reckon it must be
about given Kumari is probably about
three to four years older then Hassan I
can see the courier on my rights
I'm eternal for this because I'm hoping
they're gonna bark at him just want to
give a bit of space but you can see the
male females isn't that cool
I'm actually gonna see he's coming up
with closer not barking because I think
they pretty but they we got might have
heard it in the background almost sounds
like a dog that's barking to be trying
to stay in front of him so that you can
see him as he walks towards us because
he's got the most menacing eyes so of
course it would be them cootie barks
when I start the vehicle what's they
barked quite a bit already he's probably
why they're not making too much noise
we'll just give Maria a little bit more
space and then we'll stop again
I'll sort of try and see where I'm going
so that I don't crash all right since
you reckon that's good
think if we go a little further then
we'll have a nice straight line to a
camera as well as a lot more space that
we can work with there we go
he's probably gonna same Park on these
bushes just on the left here where the
marula is I would imagine let's see if
he does the good looks like his limpid
Sint Marky spot doesn't it let me go
he's sniffing around it might lift his
tail let's see if he does
nope he's decided he's not going to
Saint Mark there but I thought he might
looks quite close for him to do so it's
always nice to stay in front and
especially when you're gonna nip it as
relaxed as one of these guys because it
allows you these incredible views of a
lipid walking straight at you
which is always so nice rather than just
seeing the tail I'm gonna go quite a
long way now
is that nice straight road so
don't worry Rusty's not sick I'm just
still in low range from when we cross
the drainage just now sir that's why
rusty is revving as high as it is but
I'll cool with that he's just kind of
moving straight at us at the moment
there will be a nice kind of view of him
walking directly towards where we are
you can see he's just stopping and
listening every now and then Christine I
I must admit I disagree completely
Herkimer his eyes in no way remind me of
Anderson male's eyes they're completely
different colors so I don't see the
resemblance at all it's not to say that
he can't remind you of Anderson I mean
these things are possible but for me
it's not the case I don't know maybe
others are they agree with you but I
certainly don't see it for me as eyes
are a lot more orange in color
in fact his eyes are a lot more like the
mullahs eyes and his whole demeanor and
body's shape then everything looks a lot
more than will alike the in Anderson
Anderson's got these much lighter color
that's yes okay see right maybe it is
just the intensity in which he kind of
stays at you that's reminds you of that
but I don't know he just has a different
look altogether soon the tongue should
start coming out because you've been
walking for a while so hopefully we get
that tongue coming out soon isn't that a
cool picture we merely do have a nice
job don't we sender and Polly has been
absolutely spoiled this afternoon by
hokum worry all right so you want to
look into his eyes we've gotta go soon
because you know walk past us in the
meantime let's send you across to Jamie
who's managed to catch up with their
eighties we've all been spoiled this
afternoon where we go we've managed to
catch up with our elephants
there's babies here and everything I'm
just gonna turn the game Drive radio
down hello big girls
Bebe's touching in such a hurry they're
obviously really really thirsty and got
their water walk on I think they may
cross over onto the gallery oh it's big
herd
surveillance coming
moving at the speed you can really hear
them as women's their digestive products
typically quite flesh and I'm down in
this character for one all right guys
where are you in such a hurry too you're
gonna go to Chitra surely that's the
only water and this this and water
honorable gari that they might be
thinking of who just managed to catch
them and on the southern boundary of
Juma just checking to see that there is
not an elephant coming up behind us this
is an area where that's happened to me
before I mistook it for a ship no saw a
frog I didn't realize there was another
elephant still struggling behind
pa Madonna says that Madonna says that
she loves elephants and that er we have
made her day I'm thrilled to hear it I
love elephants too so they've definitely
made my day as well
Madonna it's lovely to have you watching
we do appreciate our celebrity viewers a
great deal
of course naturally I went blank I
couldn't think of one Madonna song not
one totally blanked so he code watched
him yes that one I lied I thought of one
they must surely be going to Chitra what
time is it I've gotta check the hyena
dens because they're not gonna stick
around Chitra in time for the TV show I
don't think it's too much of a risk
no you see they're not walking towards
Chitra damn they're going but further
south and unfortunately just just on the
boundary here between Chitra and about
you know huge hurry it's the first time
I've seen them actually stopped feed and
so I first spotted them sometimes you
watch hungry members of the herd yes
get the nibbles while they're being
raced along and they reach out and grab
a branch on the run that tree obviously
is irresistible whatever it is I can't
tell another light so damn looks like a
quarry which wouldn't make much sense
perhaps there's something in it they
after
no oh time to go boys I could only have
been two males hanging out at the back
cool
bob is nice brief but nice
a vehicle coming this way I might try
and find out some information about
what's happening this side I think they
think I have a leopard all right I'm
going to just go and have a chat to this
vehicle in the meantime Tristan is the
master of positioning the vehicle and
he's found himself in the perfect spot
we've reversed a long way again and
managed to get in front of a camera
who's slowly plotting his why lie along
northwards on twisted axis unfortunately
the wrong direction altogether because
we're supposed to start our show in an
hour's time and we're not going to have
this cat in an hour if he keeps this
rated and which he's going the only
saving grace is is that if he keeps on
this road he's answered well definitely
will pick up ting on a scent this is
waiting on was found this morning was on
this road so it wouldn't be surprised
that's what he's busy smelling you can
see look he's got his nose there he's
kind of checking that bush when lifting
Ghana didn't st. mark there and now it's
a battle of Saint walking and boundary
marking to make sure that each one
understands where the limits of their
boundaries are but he looks like he's
ready for a fight doesn't he it reminds
me of Mike Tyson this leopard he's got
that same kind of demeanor to him right
since I'm going to move back a little
bit further again just so we can have
the same shot very nicely and you can
have a lipid like that's the nice thing
is I've also taken it out of low range
which means you guys don't have to
listen to the whining engine of a Land
Rover
tear marks a doesn't until it sees the
male leopard so it doesn't have any idea
that it's bigger until such time as it
sees the other male and then obviously
it will realize hang on a second I'm not
as big as the other one but it will try
and vocalize and st. mark and do all
those kind of things until such time as
that lipid wall they come together and
then they'll be able to work out who's
bigger by size and in terms of knowing
if they are the leopard is bigger by
size well they stand side by side so
it's much like you as a person you can
see another person you realize very
quickly that that person is bigger are
you going to for a poo yeah lovely glad
that we all here not down there because
otherwise we're about to have driven
past that and I can promise you a
processed warthog that is been dead for
three days and then it comes out two
days later is not very pleasant at all
yes we can start calling him poo memory
maybe that could be his next litter of
Cubs his pre memory and that's what we
can maybe call those because there's
definitely stole shimmery and who could
tell you that just needs to stay um
obviously one of them unfortunately his
died from the Shatila combination but we
can still I think who could to lose the
best one that and not shimmery as much
as who could deliver could do is
definitely the better of the two names
boy you need to stop now can you not sit
down me please you've been walking for
the last hour and a half actually almost
two hours he's not listening at all
right so something that is far peuta did
in this face walking down the road to me
is the baby ellie that jamie has
currently
no cloak look how cute it is absolutely
adorable that is a relatively new little
baby elephant hi mom
you clever girl get mine here's your mom
here's your mom ketchup hey sweet offer
unfortunately disappearing onto little
Gary I want to start up because mom was
a bit nervous she's oh no she splits up
from the rest of her herd so she was
feeling a little bit unsettled she's
only got some youngsters with her he had
to be turn now so you can see the baby
running off because those little legs
are working so furiously to keep up with
mom that good dog there's long legs
trotting along behind mum ah sweet I
haven't had a good baby le sighting in
such a long time they are so precious
bye guys
that was fun while it lasted just little
feet I'm gonna see if I can find its
track although it's a bit dark and a bit
gloomy now tail held out in excitement
and straight towards water well it was
nice it was a nice little surprise
because I thought the rest of the herd
had gone and I have now little Gary
there must be water somewhere down that
side by the way I found out where the
other in Kuma's are so there's three on
Torchwood penis for at big dam on
elephant Plains or surely side
well my lips have given us the slip
fortunately James has done a marvelous
job of keeping up with husana again
everyone
there is horse honor he is giving us a
serious runaround
Judah is having the workout or arthritic
parts session II didn't expect this
afternoon just continue hello okay we've
met it
the kitty is just in front of us he's
investigating a little termite mal stop
here for a second you can hear that
we're not the only ones here Audrey too
is trying to keep up with him he has
some very noisy guests
hello chicken and Barbie that's a very
interesting question you've asked
actually there are two likely scenarios
where a leopard would be a non dominant
male one such as this chap finds himself
in now so he's not he just sort of hit
puberty he's not an adult yet and so he
lives in the domain of his father and of
other male leopards actually so he has
not always lived in his father's domain
he has been away for holidays in the
domain of the Andersen male so he's a
non dominant male leopard and then just
before retirement and permanent
retirement I mean they often do have a
period of sort of well I suppose you
might call it territorial retirement
where they don't in fact holds territory
anymore a good example would be a
leopard called a mullah who seemed not
to hold territory for the last year or
so his life but he mated I'm not sure if
it was a successful mating or not I
don't think it was but what's quite
interesting is that he did manage to
hold you know to survive without being a
territorial male we know of a leopard
called what is that leopards name we
sometimes see forgotten is forgotten his
name begins with the name anyway it's a
leopard that seems not to have had a
territory for any length of time he's
held little death sitting before Kazi
Thank You Kirsten who's held territory
for very brief periods at various stages
and we've seen him once and you know he
pops up now and again around the sabi
sands but doesn't seem to have ever
established himself like ting Ghana
armored leopard always hawk amore of
course so yeah I guess there are certain
conditions under which a male leopard
would not be territorial
but these ears got a little bit mangled
ear on the right hand side and on the
left actually this is a sign of coming
adulthood
this is ting gonna this is not a sauna
yeah the sistine goner
where's husana because we do definitely
following hisana
we found another leopard right in the
same area he's in front of us here he
comes he's just behind us we've got both
yep it's here right here just behind
that Bush this is amazing
I was just looking at this cat's ears
and thinking that's very odd
and then it is spot pattern Ethel
imagine phew I thought I'd lost my mind
this guy can tell you exactly what's
happened here
Dingaan has come out of the drainage
line I don't think he knows what's on
this behind him
well saunas be totally silent behind me
watch me father he's watching him
dang god I can smell of course at this
Olympic there are dia
no sauna standing they'd still just
behind him
and of course with all the birds making
such a noise this is just so special
everybody oh look and Hasan is following
dad now
or trying to sneak away from him
yes now he's following his father just
watch it in Ghana behind you there sips
about to climb onto sibs lap from behind
naturally of course by the time we go
live for the TV show there will be no
limits anywhere aren't here but for now
we'll just enjoy it
sorry I can't move around in Ghana still
sitting right behind us
and husana behind that bouche
you're all worried there's going to be a
fight well there might be a chase I
don't think I'd be a fighter
yeah what is he looking towards the
other side he's walking away now yeah
he's just walking away behind us
no sign of watching I don't know who
just stay with I think we were probably
gonna stay with or sauna he's slightly
more tolerant but in Ghana's not gonna
give up yeah I think on our nose is
another lipid yeah y'all Kirsten let's
go for an unscheduled and see what
happens
good evening we are sitting here on the
western fringes of the great Kruger
National Park watching a very
interesting scene unfolding the young
male leopard horse Anna is over there
and he's following his father who has
smelt his presence and doesn't know
exactly where his son is my name is
James Henry we've got Sebastian on
camera and we've got a very interesting
family dynamic unfolding here
Kasana just over three years old ten
Ghana a thirteen year old male aunt in
Ghana has gone off behind us I don't
want to move just yet hasanah is
watching Tenggara just to clarify or
sauna is Dingaan a son
it's just got dark here in the western
Kruger it's just after hospice 5:00 in
the afternoon and if they do meet we're
going to be fascinated to see what
happens I suspect the father will chase
son but it is interesting that the son
is following father despite the fact
that father is really clearly looking
for son since he looks a little bit
nervous he's still smaller than his dad
yes Timothy as you say Father's Day is
next week all right well there goes for
sauna
he's walking as quietly as possible
there are other vehicles with us if you
hear the dim crackle of rifle fire it's
not rifles actually it's just cameras
taking bulgaria gio crafts i'm just
gonna stand up and look behind us
i can't see the other mail
are you sneaking away now I don't think
they're actually going to meet they were
about to meet almost entirely by chance
quite fascinating we were watching one
came around the bush saw a lit but
assumed it was the same one and it
wasn't it was actually the Sun at least
the father just let's have a look down
here there is listing Ghana fathers now
watching he's approaching the Sun and
you see him said he's just gone behind
that bush I'm gonna go forward there is
a lot of thick pushing everybody so if
you do hear crunching and crashing I'm
sorry he's running now dad is running
yep running straight ahead of us a big
woosh there's a hyena as well this
quickly there's a hyena just off to the
left unbelievable stuff we've got the
leopard now slowly walking in front of
us just in a splash of that light let's
carry on you got in there yeah there is
that's the father that's ting Ghana
this is a quite spectacular afternoon
I'm just gonna nip in front of a candy
that said we can keep going forward yeah
I can see them both now father is on
Suns tail and I don't know that we'll be
able to see them though if I stop just
see husana in front of ting Ghana he's
now being stalked
of course [ __ ] son is should be able to
get a few just behind this bush here
there is ting gonna
they're better they're straight in front
just to the right death you say your
heart rate just jumped yes minder - I'm
gonna carry on save just get around
these bushes I'm asanas just in front
here
there this asana and Kangana coming up
now behind assume you says it's really
live absolutely it is that's why you're
seeing it warts and all with me parking
behind bushes when I shouldn't be and us
trying desperately to get into a
position where we can see them both I
can just see them the camera's not
picking them up because it's dark but it
will rest in Ghana will sign up probably
just about to pop out on this game path
in front of us
they're arresting Ghana that's in Ghana
definitely you can see the dewlap he's
much heavier than his son
no no that's you've got a sauna there
and his father's just behind him I'm
gonna move quick sip
yeah this nest in Ghana behind him
that's ten Ghana
looking for his son and I think asana
has probably just dipped down into this
drainage line there's a fight and
fighting yeah there was a big growling
match and father chase son away I'm
afraid I don't know if we're gonna get a
view in yet
here we go there we go they're straight
to the lift it's a bush naturally in the
way there they go
running straight up that way so they
said can you turn that light off a
little bit I'm blinded I can't see
anything
yeah thank you sorry about this
everybody it is very exciting trying to
keep up with what's going on here there
we go one dip it in front that's ten
Ghana
now I don't know if you heard that well
I bet Red River that was husana shouting
and I'm sorry you didn't see them both
but it was impossible for me to get into
the position without a bush in the way
I'm sorry the car is also very noisy but
it's impossible through here I'm afraid
I can hear her sounder calling he's
calling where's he's just to the right I
don't think he's gone up a tree sorry we
want this move
and possible to keep up these things in
the day let alone at night like this
this is fantastically exciting but now
ting Ghana has been up until this point
extremely tolerant of his son there we
have 10 Ghana
that's 10 Ghana I think and I think Osan
is just in front of him there you can
hear him shouting this is bizarre
because that's to Ghana that's lying
down I'm going to move slightly forward
sit
and see if we can't see them both
there's 10 Ghana
and I say it was interesting because up
until this point
ting Ghana has been tolerant of asana
but not anymore
asana is somewhere around here growling
you can see the saliva coming out of his
mouth there that's very difficult of
livers who are having a territorial find
he's not growling at all
I think it's not far from here I'm just
gonna shine my Sparkle up into this area
see if I can get a sign of horse honor
there is gusta /gc he's just in there
you can just see his eyes shiny
I'm not gonna he's just in there you
won't see him with the camera but that's
where he is I just saw his eyes shining
behind that Bush there
it's decanting ghana for now
I said it was very strange that he
should have lie laying down like he did
there
because that's almost submissive but you
can see he's not being submissive at all
he's angry now leopards who are having a
battle will often just lie next to each
other like this
David horse Allah does want to be left
to learn to a certain extent but he
almost thought his father out he could
easily have snuck away but he didn't he
waited and then followed his dad for a
while and then turned and moved away but
then Kangana picked up the scent but
we've watched asana approach other
leopards countless times as a youngster
he's now moving into adulthood and so
that behavior should listen
a number of you commenting on the
spotlight and asking you nuts blinding
him said you're not blinding him
is it affecting the fight no I don't
think it is these cats are very used to
the spotlights very used to the vehicles
he's just in the bush behind there let's
see if he follows okay I'm gonna move
and I gonna get a view of asana will do
is quickly see if we can get a view of
asana and if we can and we will close
with that
otherwise yeah here we go he's gonna
follow his father again this is
unbelievable can you see him this it I
was gonna reverse back slightly not be
able to see him
we don't want to dis get caught in
between and I don't know if there was a
physical contact or not but now he
continues you see this is what this cat
does he's looking for his father he's
looking for trouble I don't think it's a
territorial thing that he's doing he's
just right here
smelling where his dad was
absolutely fascinating interaction that
I'm sorry we didn't get to see it all
but I'm sure you've got your impression
of how exciting it was sorry about the
antenna there I can't move currently
because it's a small traffic jam on me
okay I think we're going to probably in
this aisle to see if I can have another
quick look wasn't that absolutely
astounding watching a father letter to
chase his son telling him to get out of
the house and be a man my son
absolutely great all right we'll say
goodbye to you and hope that you enjoyed
that and if you want to keep on watching
just go to youtube type in Safari live
and you can watch the rest of our drive
and we have an hour-long TV show
starting on top of six as well so you
can what's up - thanks very much for
joining us
ok everybody what did you think of that
that was pretty interesting I think
we're gonna stay with asana I'm not
gonna try and find ting garni he seems
to have gone off into the thick stuff
down towards the right we might have
them both again at some stage absolutely
amazing stuff and internal fear so that
he can get that is husana or I should
just go back to yet another livid with
Tristan and moody
now he's chasing his father
well James good lucks following both
boys sins he's just there you can see
him we're still with Herkimer you can
see his tails just there but he's
probably about it's not even two minutes
from crossing into some abilities the
chances of us having him for much longer
is almost gone which is typical this is
how a Sunday often works is that you'll
spend most of your day following a lipid
Lynette it will move off just before
things or before we really need him to
be around which is for obviously our TV
show just now anyway he's stalking
something now so let's hope that he
settles and actually stalks it's why
I've got no lights on it's why I'm not
moving as well as because he was
watching something and so I have no idea
what it is we're gonna try and follow in
the meantime let it send you back across
to husana who's still watching ting
Ghana I think there's about to be
another confrontation here everybody
I can't talk now Jamie sorry Jamie just
trying to get hold of me on the game
drive ray do you know what's going on
yeah I think he's definitely seen two
gone in yet
[Music]
now they're in the thick stuff now
they're in the thickest of the thick you
see them he went in there no we can't go
different we can't go in there I have no
idea what's going on now I'm afraid oh
you know in a serious bind I'm just
gonna nudge this quarry
II ran down here can't hear see as I
predicted of course by the time we go
live for our TV show we will have
nothing to look at
yeah I'm afraid that's it everybody I
can't get any further I'm just gonna
have to listen and see if we can't maybe
go round and him up
here we go there's a bit of noise here
does it look like they've got him behind
us this it
now
deeply frustrating janta phone through
all those bushes
what have you got in there
all right I think let's go across to
Jamie there all right sorry I've just
been discussing with Davi we're trying
to help James out here as much as we can
especially in case if her Sanne turns
and runs we're gonna try either keep up
with him or stay with Singhania just
depends upon what they're doing and
because they're in a thick drainage line
here no the strange line really really
well we're using the FLIR to look up
ahead in case they pop out so we just
basically acting as backup for James
shame I've been trying to get hold of
him on the game Drive radio but he's
concentrating so hard on what's going on
it's very tricky to juggle everything so
we're scanning really carefully with the
flare up ahead it's just the road all I
can see are trees and there's nothing
really that's popped out yeah so whether
a spotlight was up ahead and I don't see
anything in the FLIR yet I'm trying to
decide if it's worth our while going
forward but I don't think so I think
we'll hear them what's that there does
is that a that's a branch it's just the
tree
you think I'm overexcited by any chance
possibly I don't think they're going to
split I think they're going to stay
together for the duration of the TV show
but I don't know I can't make that call
so I'm just sitting here in case they
decide to split up and then we'll step
in we're trying to help James keep track
so that's our plan such as it is you can
see obviously how much further the FLIR
can see then the in oh my goodness
gracious moth all right while we sit
here and wait Hoku Maury has very kindly
obliged Tristan and has finally laid
down
Okumura unfortunately is about to cross
our T's very very close to Triple Aim
nard and they were in having much more
than two minutes the good news is is
that somehow there is some well I might
speak a little bit soon I'll have to
double-check but apparently two of
ochres have just crossed in right north
of where we are right now as well so the
problem with that is that's right up
against the gates area and so they could
either go into the manually or they
could come our way but we're gonna try
and see I'm the seller for Camry while
he crosses a stand and I'll try and
relocates on the male's just now but
they should be just north of where we
are at the moment
interestingly enough what come when he's
not change direction is hitting straight
north which is quite strange and his
nose is to the ground I don't know what
he's smelling we are you boy and see now
he's on the trail of something that's
for sure because he's really nose down
very quickly at the moment if you watch
him coming out of that area now you'll
see how his nose is down and then he's
Fleming grimacing as well which is quite
interesting
whatever you smell - boy and he walked
past the Dyke here just now which I
think he just decided was no good for
him that's - you - too fast he's a
preferred slower animals pastures what
are you smelling boy I'm intrigued by
what is he could potentially be smelling
I honestly have no idea what could be of
walkshare
it's not like we've had any tracks when
he lipids or seen any lipids up the side
and he briefly scented waiting on was
this morning exactly they hadn't sent
marked over waiting on a st. marked and
then just carried on so ever see the
society not worth following ting garna
but something else has piqued his
interest here massively and like I say
his direction has changed slightly why
he's still angling westwards he's much
more kind of in a northerly direction
than he was previously
everyone was wondering about him heading
towards Singhania and Hassan if he heard
the noises undoubtedly yes Mel lipid his
are the lipids fighting he's gonna go
and see what's going on anything is is
that I mean he's too far now to hear it
that's for sure I don't think he'll hate
that way just yet well you never know
actually things can change quickly but
at this stage I don't think so he
doesn't seem like he's hating anywhere
near they in fact what we doing is just
going straight north of the stage which
we can't do much longer because
eventually we going to hit the gates so
at that point it would be interesting to
see if he's gonna turn but my gut feel
says he's gonna go west and he's gonna
move away from this area I don't think
he wants to have any sort of
confrontation with Dingaan at this stage
because he's smoked in Ghana and he
hasn't trailed him at all so maybe he's
just decided he's happy going the way
that he's going nice he's cutting now
back east again which is interesting I
don't know if he's going because he
smelt something here but at this rate
he's going to bump into two male lions
which I can assure you he doesn't want
to bump into but as much as he doesn't
want to bump into ting honor to male
lions is worse he's gonna have to be a
bit careful about the way that he goes
about things I don't know if they maybe
this is rating on a walked this morning
note in Ghana was around but I don't
think he came this far west I think tin
ghana went more sort of towards all
breeze before so cut line but what's on
I mean Tinker welcome worried should I
say sorry there's all these lipids
around today seems to be kind of walking
with something on his mind and some sort
of scent that he's trailing incredible
animal there isn't he say what you want
he might not be everyone's favorite but
I like it I think he's got something
about him that is quite special he's
with this look and this kind of wild
demeanor which suggests liquid in my
eyes there he goes just crossing behind
sensors bottom turn into the darkness
again eyes changed back directly waist
again so
he's going to send mark there and sniff
about there's obviously something that
he's smelled that he doesn't agree with
and you're pretty sure we're not gonna
have him on this evenings TV show I'm
almost 99% sure of that but at least we
had an epic time with him this afternoon
and I hope all of you are going to be
tuning in to the TV show remember it
starts in about half an hour's time
because the hasana Tenggara incident or
fight might carry on long into the
evening
anyway it's that time though where we
need to say goodbye and so from from
hooker murray and all of us it's been an
absolute pleasure hopefully we'll see
you all just now and again tomorrow
morning for the sentences rise Safari
[Music]